Wir blicken auf die verrückte Reise von Preußen Münster in die 2. Bundesliga und den entfesselt aufspielenden 1. FC Magdeburg und das zusammen mit Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast und Sven Scholz vom Fernsehen 06. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Rasenfunk und zur Ligatur, in diesem Fall der Zweitligaliga-Tour der Männer. Herzlich willkommen und für alle, die mich vielleicht noch nicht kennen oder vielleicht doch schon etwas kennen aus anderen Formaten. Ich stelle mich nochmal vor, mein Name ist Marc Schwitzky, ich bin freier Sportjournalist, vor allen Dingen beim RWB24 zu lesen und bei Hertha Base zu hören. Und wenn ihr die letzte Zweitligasendung mit Eva-Lotta Bohle nicht gehört haben solltet, dann erzähle ich euch diesen Fakt nochmal. Ansonsten müsst ihr es halt nochmal über euch ergehen lassen. Max hat keine Befugnis mehr über dieses Format, das haben Eva und ich gekapert und werden in zukunft zusammen das Zweitligaformat, die Ligatur moderieren im zweiewöchentlichen Wechsel. Letztes Mal hatte Eva, gehört jetzt mich. Also einmal pro Monat dann eine Person von beiden und dementsprechend freue ich mich da sehr darüber, dass wir dieses Format jetzt hier zusammen machen dürfen. Und ich freue mich auch, weil wir in diesem Fall wieder zwei wunderbare Gäste haben. Zum einen Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM-Podcast. Grüß dich, hi!
Ja, hallo Marc, danke für die Einladung.
Und Sven Scholz vom Fernseher 06 wird uns heute etwas über Preußen Münster erzählen. Grüß dich, Sven.
Guten Abend, sehr gerne. Danke für die Einladung.
Guck mal, das hat jetzt super geklappt. Ein Blick hinter die Kulissen. Wir machen das hier gefühlt zum siebten Mal, aber es klang immer noch wie frisch. Da sagt man, da sind Profis am Werk, aber Technik macht mal manchmal, was sie will. Damit wir das auch in zukunft alles hier machen können, werdet doch Teil der Rasenfunk-Familie und werdet zum Rasenfunk-Unterstützer oder Unterstützerin. Denn ihr wisst, sprecht es mir nach, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Und das geht durch Leute wie beispielsweise sehrgutsch, BJ, Thomas aus Soling, Fritz Espung, Jan und Fabian. Sie alle unterstützen den Podcast hier, den Rasenfunk, finanziell. Wie ihr das machen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Dort könnt ihr alles weitere erfahren, wie das geht. Jeder Euro hilft und macht eben möglich, dass Max sich noch stärker auf seine Sendung konzentrieren kann und Eva und ich das Privileg haben, diese Sendung moderieren zu dürfen. Nur so funktioniert das und auch, dass die Gäste wie Thomas wie Sven ein kleines Honorar für ihre Zeit bekommen. Wenn das funktioniert, ist das doch wunderbar. Und dementsprechend können wir jetzt in die Sendung auch inhaltlich starten und starten mit der allgemeinen Lage der Liga. Es war ein wilder Spieltag in der Zweitliga, aber das ist ja ja so oft. Beginnen würde ich gerne kurz mit natürlich dem Franken-Durby, denn da sind ganz kurzfristig noch Breaking News reingekommen, denn Kräuter Fürth wagt den sportlichen Neuanfang und möchte die Sportlichführung des Vereins neu strukturieren. Sowohl der Trainer Alexander Zorniger als auch Manager Rachid Azusi mussten ihre Plätze räumen. Dafür jetzt Leo Haas als Cheftrainer bis zur Winterpause da und Stefan Fürsten als sportlicher Leiter, der die sportlichen Geschicke leiten wird. Aber warum überhaupt? Tja, das Franken-Durby ging ordentlich in die Binden. Dieses hat nämlich Nürnberg mit 4 zu 0 Furios für sich entscheiden können und sogar bei Miro Klose, dem Trainer der Klubberer, für Tränen sorgen können. Und bereits vor der Niederlage hatte das Kleeblatt vier Spiele hinter andern nicht gewonnen, nur zwei Punkte geholt und das ist jetzt das Ende. Sven, wie blickst du auf die Lage im Frankenland?
Ja, wenn man mal schaut, es gab mal eine Saison, wo Bremen und Schalke abgestiegen sind, dann haben sie den wieder direkten Aufstieg gemacht. Greuther Fürth hat sich im Mittelfeld der 2. Liga etabliert. Für mich ist das ein Schnellschuss, weil man genau dieses Derby dann verloren hatte. Bei anderen Vereinen wird ruhiger gearbeitet. Ich verstehe die Personalien nicht, weil ich den Zorniger eigentlich als sehr guten Trainer fand. Wir haben ja gegen Fürth leider verloren. Ja, aber man steht jetzt nicht schlechter da, als man sich in den Saisons nach dem Abstieg auch sich dann am Ende platziert hatte. Also von daher ist man, glaube ich, im Soll. Wenn man jetzt andere Ansprüche hat, dann wird jemand wahrscheinlich dann die Reißleine ziehen. Das ist dann nicht der Trainer und nicht der Co-Trainer oder sportlicher Direktor, sondern eine Ebene drüber. Ich verstehe es nicht. Also es ist schon sehr extrem zu dem Zeitpunkt in der Liga.
Spannend ist eben auch, dass sie den Verein jetzt sportlich grundlegend verändern wollen. Also vielleicht kommt da auch wirklich eine ganz andere Strategie. Bislang führt ja auch ein Verein, der sehr für die Ausbildung junger, deutscher Talente steht, die teilweise entweder aus 2. Mannschaften geholt werden, ausgeliehen werden oder sogar aus 4. Ligen geholt werden. Auch ein ähnliches Modell, wie er beispielsweise auch der SC Paderborn-Teilse fährt, bloß führt, führt das immer wieder in die Extreme. Und apropos gute Jugendarbeit, der FC Schalke 04 hat einen neuen Trainer, Kees van Wonderen heißt dieser Mann. Und er konnte die Probleme nicht durch Zauberhand davon hexen. Er selber hat ja auch gesagt, ich bin kein Harry Potter. Und das wurde schnell bekannt, obwohl er sich in die Kammer des Schreckens bewegt hat. Und dementsprechend jetzt nach der 0 zu 1 Niederlage gegen Hannover, erstmal schauen muss, was jetzt die wirklichen Problemzonen sind. Denn der FC Schalke 04, wie gesagt, hat das erste Spiel unter dem neuen Trainer verloren. Wenn auch knapp, aber mit 0,2 x g auch nicht wirklich viel produziert. Thomas, was glaubst du, wo geht die Reise für Schalke jetzt in den nächsten Wochen hin? Was sollte erstmal das Ziel sein?
Ja, das ist, Schalke ist krass. Also ich mag mir gar nicht ausmalen, wenn so ein Verein wie Schalke tatsächlich in die dritte Liga runtergehen sollte. Die haben ja letztes Jahr schon, finde ich, zum Ende hin gut Glück gehabt, dass sie drin geblieben sind. Die Hinrunde war ja letzte Saison schon eine Katastrophe. Da war es tatsächlich dann auch erst der Trainerwechsel, der dann so ein bisschen was bewirkt hat. Diese Saison, ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Also ich habe nicht verstanden, warum er mit Gerrard weitergemacht hat. Ich fand die Leistung jetzt auch nicht so überzeugend in der letzten Saison unter ihm. Klar, sie haben die Klasse gehalten. Aber es hat sich ja dann offenbar bestätigt, dass es dann vielleicht doch nicht der richtige Trainer war für Schalke, was auch immer da jetzt ein Anforderungsprofil sein soll. Aber ich glaube, auch da ist es ein Thema, was vielleicht eine Ebene höher anzusiedeln ist. Also aus meiner Perspektive von ganz weit weg. Ich glaube, der Kader ist einfach nicht gut zusammengestellt. Und klar, man hat da wirklich auch sehr, sehr gute 2. Liga-Spieler wie eben Karaman zum Beispiel. Aber ansonsten, ich glaube, die Mannschaft ist einfach nicht gut zusammengestellt. Und das sieht man jetzt. Und ich glaube, Schalke wird bis zum Saisonende wieder eher nach unten gucken müssen, wenn da jetzt nicht eine Komplettdrehung in der Winterpause passiert.
Bis zuletzt hat ja auch der SV Darmstadt nach unten geguckt. Aber der Trainerwechsel, auch wenn es sicherlich zu früh ist für eine endgültige Bewertung, fruchtet durchaus. Unter Florian Kohfeldt 8 Punkte aus 5 Spielen und nun den 1. FC Köln mit 5 zu 1 vom Rasen gefegt. Sven, wie überrascht warst du von diesem Ergebnis und von der auch Kölner Leistung?
Also generell muss man sagen, ist es natürlich da, wo wir gerade stehen, sehr überraschend, dass jetzt Darmstadt performt. Da hat es wahrscheinlich gezündet, dass da Veränderungen in der Mannschaft, im Teamstaff vonstattengegangen sind. Würde man sich ja bei uns auch, ist natürlich dann aber sehr überraschend, weil 1. FC Köln ist eigentlich die Mannschaft mit dem höchsten Marktwert in der 2. Bundesliga. Die haben aber natürlich nicht diese Transfersperre so gut kompensieren können. Das ist natürlich ein ganz anderer Einschnitt, den du hast. Ich weiß es nicht, ob man vielleicht genau eben als Absteiger mit dem Potenzial, was man vielleicht in dem Kader hat, gesagt hat, okay, alles da, wir kriegen das schon irgendwie hin. Und jetzt kommt man an. Und die anderen wollen ja auch aufsteigen. Also von daher, ich finde, die 2. Bundesliga generell so ein bisschen so 50-50 gemischt. Die eine Hälfte kann absteigen, die andere Hälfte will aufsteigen. Es ist sehr interessant, wenn man sich die letzten Saisons anguckt, wie close es gerade ist zwischen allen Teams. Und wie gesagt, Darmstadt hat jetzt in Schalke was gedreht. Darmstadt hat jetzt Köln 5-1 weggefegt. Niemals zu erwarten. So in der Konstellation, wo du herkommst als Team. Sehr interessant, sehr überraschend. Warum, weiß ich nicht. Aber der Kader von Darmstadt ist einfach auch viel, viel besser zu bewerten, als was die Tabellensituation vor drei, vier Spieltagen hergegeben hat. Das muss man auch ganz fair sagen.
Durchaus. Und bei Köln ist nach wie vor natürlich das Problem, krasse Offensivwucht, unter dem neuen Trainer entwickeln können bislang. Schießen sehr viele Tore, Schießer haben sehr hohe Expected Goals-Werte und so weiter. Aber das täuscht ein wenig darüber hinweg, dass eben noch gar keine defensive Stabilität erreicht wurde. Und dadurch eben auch eine fehlende Konstanz. Denn man hat erst drei Spiele gewonnen in dieser Saison. Und das gegen Braunschweig, Schalke und Ulm. Also wenn man das mal so nüchtern betrachtet, sieht das wirklich gar nicht so gut aus. Aber ich, für mich muss sagen, mein Bauchgefühl hat Köln bislang viel besser eingeschätzt. Und dann guckt man auf die tatsächliche Punkteausbeute und die Siege und stellt fest, ach so, das ist ja gar nicht so gut. Ich glaube, da täuscht manchmal der spektakuläre Spielstil etwas über die Ergebnisse hinweg. Aber Thomas, du als Magdeburg-Fan kennst das ja bestens.
Also bei uns täuscht gar nichts über irgendwas hinweg. Wir stehen da, wo uns eben völlig verdient. Nein, also ich merke gerade vielleicht noch mal auf Köln ganz kurz. Man muss natürlich auch sagen, die Nieler gegen uns z.B., die war schon aus Kölner sich, glaube ich, sehr, sehr unglücklich. Also ich habe nach dem Spiel gesagt, da wissen beide Mannschaften eigentlich nicht, warum sie als Gewinner und Verlierer auf den Platz gehen. Normal muss uns Köln da zur Halbzeit 4-0 schon aus dem Schalon geknallt haben. Machen sie nicht, weil sie die Chancen nicht nutzen. Das gleiche Problem hatten sie unter anderem auch gegen Düsseldorf, wo sie ein sehr, sehr gutes Spiel machen in meinen Augen. Und dann in Düsseldorf in der Nachspielzeit unglücklich das 2-2 kassieren. Also wenn man mal diese beiden Spiele nimmt und sagt, die Spiele nehmen ihren normalen Verlauf, dann haben sie fünf Punkte mehr. Ich glaube, dann reden wir bei Köln auch ein bisschen anders. Ich denke, dass bei Köln das wird noch klappen. Also wenn der Abstand von Köln in der Winterpause nicht allzu groß ist nach oben, glaube ich, dann werden die in der Rückrunde massiv oben angreifen und die werden definitiv auch was machen. Ich glaube, da muss einfach ein Stürmer her. Das fehlt, das sieht man. Chancen haben sie genug. Sie haben einfach keinen Knipser. Und wenn sie den haben und der wird im Winter kommen, da gehe ich fest von aus, dann glaube ich, wird Köln in der Rückrunde noch eine ganz, ganz große Rolle spielen in der Liga.
Ich erinnere mich auch an das Auftaktspiel gegen den HSV, welches ja auch Köln kurioserweise nicht für sich entscheiden konnte. Auch das war ja durchaus ein Spiel, was anders hätte ausgehen können. Und trotz der vielen Torchancen und trotz der, des fehlenden Schirmers stehen ja Leute wie Damian Downs oder Tim Lemperle auch schon bei 4 oder 3 Toren. Zeigt, was da mit einem echten Knipser vielleicht möglich wäre. Jemand, der das dringend bräuchte, ist der Jan aus Regensburg. Die Statistiken geistern schon ein wenig durch das Netz. Hat man das Gefühl, es ist ein dramatisch schlechter Saisonstart. Nach der 0 zu 3 Niederlage jetzt gegen Tabellenführer Düsseldorf sind es nur 4 Punkte, was vielleicht sogar irgendwo noch verkraftbar wäre. Denn der Anschluss ist ja noch durchaus da. Aber vor allen Dingen natürlich das Torverhältnis von 1 zu 22 in neun Spielen ist schon wirklich brutal. Sven, ihr seid quasi mit Jan Regensburg gemeinsam aufgestiegen. Glaubst du, dass das sich noch drehen kann? Wie hast du die Regensburger vielleicht auch in der letzten Saison wahrgenommen?
Also, wir haben ja den klarsten Sieg gegen Regensburg gefeiert, mit einem 3 zu 0. Da ist auch irgendwie nicht so viel angebrannt. Deswegen, das war für uns wahrscheinlich auch die Mannschaft, die– ja, weitaus schlechter, will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber gefühlt eben gerade von der Performance weit hinter uns liegt, weil wir bis zu dem Zeitpunkt gegen Regensburg eigentlich relativ gute Partien abgeliefert haben. Von daher ist es schon erstaunlich. Also ein Tor, ich glaube, das gab es in den letzten, ich weiß nicht, gab es das überhaupt in den letzten zehn Jahren?
Ich habe die Statistik nicht gewälzt, aber wird selten gewesen sein.
Ich habe jetzt mal so ein bisschen durchgeklickt, gerade so bis zum neunten Spieltag, die letzten drei Jahre. Nee, da hat zumindest jedes Team auf dem letzten Platz sechs Tore geschossen. Hatte aber auch nicht unbedingt mehr Punkte, muss man auch sagen. Da gibt es dann einen Ingolstadt mit vier Punkten. Dass sie dann noch ihre vier Punkte jetzt erst mal geholt haben, ja, da stehen sie. Das kann man aber auch umschwenken. Wenn du jetzt einfach mal wieder so einen direkten Sieg feierst, im nächsten Spiel vielleicht ein Unentschieden, dann hast du schon wieder vier Punkte, vielleicht mehr. Und dann weißt du nicht, was in der Mannschaft passiert. Die sind momentan genau so, genau wie du sagst, das kursiert im Netz, das kriegen die Spieler mit, das kriegt der Verein mit, das geistert rum. Das aus den Köpfen erst mal zu kriegen, wenn du diese Hähme abbekommst, ihr seid aufgestiegen, ihr gehört in die Drittliga, das kriegen wir auch mit als Preußen Münster. Schwierig, es ist schwierig, da rauszukommen, aber ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass man mit 1 zu 22 Toren, das ist so 1. Bundesliga, Tennis Borussia, Berlin, glaube ich, war das damals. Ist schon heftig und das musst du erst mal abfangen, verdauen können, um irgendwie wieder angreifen zu können. Aber was ist die Motivation?
Es ist aber diese Saison sowieso ein bisschen spannend, auch was die Aufsteiger angeht, finde ich. Wenn man da in der letzten Saison zum Beispiel denkt, mit Elbersberg, die ja dann auch, ich sage mal, nicht furios gestartet sind im Jahr davor, hatten wir ja auch einen einigermaßen guten Saisonstart. Vor allem Kaiserslautern hatte ja eine überragende Hinrunde gespielt im Aufstieg damals, nach dem Aufstieg damals. Also es ist das erste Mal, glaube ich, seitdem wir jetzt aufgestiegen sind, habe ich so ein bisschen mehr auf dem Schirm vor drei Jahren. Es ist das erste Mal, dass die Aufsteiger auch jetzt nach zehn Spielen alle unten drin hängen. Also das war jetzt lange nicht so. Oder also die letzten drei Jahre zumindest nicht. Jetzt ist es wieder so, dass alle drei Aufsteiger unten drin hängen. Ich meine, das ist ja das, was man ein Stück weit auch realistisch erwarten kann. Gerade bei, ohne da jetzt Münster, Sven, du weißt, wie es meine. Aber es ist halt natürlich, wenn du so einen Durchmarsch machst, es ist natürlich unheimlich schwierig. Du ringst von zwei Jahren zwei Ligen hoch und das ist ja dann auch nicht einfach, da sofort auf Zweiligerniveau zu kommen. Und deswegen ist das dieses Jahr schon ein bisschen schräg. Also schräg krass, dass alle drei Aufsteiger wirklich massiv unten drin hängen und keiner so ein bisschen so, ja, so eine kleine Überraschungsrolle spielt.
Ab da dann sage ich jetzt, sorry, wenn ich jetzt nochmal eingerätsche. Die Neulinge waren in der Saison davor, Wiesbaden, Osternbrück und Elbersberg. Elbersberg auf Platz 11 mit 12 Punkten, Wiesbaden mit 9, Osternbrück mit 6. So, interessant ist, dass die Absteiger aus der ersten Bundesliga auch im Mittelfeld waren, die zwei, wie es gab. Und von daher, ich glaube, das ist schon, die zweite Liga ist schon so ein Piranha-Becken. Also entweder gehst du komplett durch, du musst es schon auffangen, es ist schon nicht ohne. Von daher finde ich das sehr interessant, wenn man einfach mal den neunten Spieltag mit der Saison vergleicht zur Saison davor.
Wie passend, dass wir heute mit dir dann auch über Preußen Münster reden können. Das passt ja dann perfekt in die Thematik. Aber vorher wollen wir sehr gerne über den ersten FC Magdeburg sprechen. Das hat er sich verdient, weil er vorne in der Tabelle steht. 16 Punkte nach neun Spielen. Er ist jetzt mit dem 1 zu 3 gegen den HSV die 1. Saison-Liederlage kassiert. Vielleicht erst mal konkret zu diesem Spiel, Thomas. Was ist denn gegen Hamburg schiefgelaufen?
Alles. Also, ja, ich glaube, Christian Thies hat sich auch ein bisschen verzockt. Der hatte dann das erste Mal jetzt die Saison dann auch mit Daniel Heber, der Innenverteidiger ist bei uns. Der hat den auf der rechten Schiene spielen lassen. Der war ja komplett überfordert gegen seinen Gegenspieler auf der linken Seite. Das war ein Grund. Er hat es dann auch schnell korrigiert. Auch die auf der rechten Seite, auch die linke Defensivseite von uns, hat er ja dann zur Halbzeit schon komplett korrigiert. Von daher, ja, war einfach ein gebrauchter Tag. Jetzt muss man natürlich auch sagen, Hamburg ist ja nur, auch wenn sie jetzt seit sieben Jahren in der zweiten Liga spielen, es ist trotzdem eine bockstarke Mannschaft. Und was die da die ersten 45 Minuten gegen uns gespielt haben, ich hatte phasenweise den Eindruck, da spielten zwei gegen den Drittligisten. Das war so stark. Die hatten in allen Belangen einfach besser. Aber da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist etwas, was ich auch unserer Mannschaft absolut zugestehe, nach diesem wirklich furiosen Saisonstart. Wir sind alle super zufrieden hier. Im Vergleich zur letzten Saison ist schon eine klare Änderung erkennbar auf der einen oder anderen Ebene. Und es macht einfach Spaß, der Mannschaft zuzugucken, vor allem auch, weil man in Hamburg natürlich auch geschuldet hat der Blöde von Schodl in der Situation, wo er einfach dort den Ball vertendet und dann den Cast stoppt. Und ab dem Moment, fand ich, war es ein komplett anderes Spiel. Da waren wir wesentlich besser im Spiel, konnten auch unsere Qualitäten wieder zeigen. Gut, das hat am Ende nicht gereicht, weil er in Hamburg auch schon drei Tore hatte. Aber letzten Endes ist das auch eine Nierlage, die, glaube ich, in unserem Umfeld auch jeder irgendwo, ja, nicht, wie er erwartet hat, aber richtig einzuschätzen weiß. Und der Saisonstart, wie gesagt, mit 16 Punkten aus neuen Spielen, super. Also, das ist einfach toll, wenn man das so sieht. Und ich hoffe, dass es so weitergeht.
Du sprichst es an, davor standen ja eben acht Spiele ohne Niederlage und mit bereits vier Siegen. Führ uns doch vielleicht gerne mal durch diesen bisherigen Saisonverlauf. Magdeburg hatte nämlich keine sonderlich gute Rückgründe 2023, 2024, wenn ich mir die Ergebnisse mal angeguckt habe. Gab es daraus irgendwelche Lehren und hat Trainer Christian Tietz vielleicht auch dadurch daraus Anpassungen hervorgeholt? Wie ist dieser gute Saison statt zu erklären?
Ich denke schon, also was eine Lehre war, das hat Christian Tietz selbst auch, dass er in der Rückrunde schon auch ein bisschen defensiver agieren wollte. Also es war ja schon auch in der letzten Saison so ein großes Problem. Offensiv ist das ja seitdem Christian Tietz da ist, ein Fußball, der ja schon begeistert. Also man kann ja nicht sagen, war ein langweiliges Spiel, es ist ja immer etwas los bei uns. Und da hat aber so ein bisschen immer die defensive Stabilität gefehlt und das war vor allem auch in der letzten Saison so, gerade in der Rückrunde. Dann kam dazu, dass wir einfach, wir hatten einfach keinen Stürmer, also keinen, der in der Lage war, da vorne auch Chancen zu nutzen und Tore zu machen. Ja und dann kam mit eins zum anderen und ich glaube schon, dass man jetzt in dieser Saison, gerade im Sommer auch mit dem Blick auf die Transfers, die man getätigt hat, hat man schon auch Dinge verändert ein Stück weit. Also ich finde mit gerade mit Matießen, die man ja von Wiesbaden geholt hat, hat man hinten auch endlich mal eine Kante geholt. Christian Thies ist ja eher dafür bekannt, so kleinere wendige Spieler zu holen, die dribbelstark sind. Gut, jetzt ist Matießen ein Abwehrspieler, da muss er nicht unbedingt dribbeln können. Aber es war schon verwundere ich, dass er einen Spieler geholt hat, der mal größer als 1,90 ist. Und der bringt schon auch eine gute Stabilität rein. Also er spielt ja dann jetzt in unserer Dreierreihe diesen Innenpart, der dann im Spielaufbau mit dem Ball auf die 6 geht und dann gegen den Ball auf die zentrale Innenverteidigerposition. Und das merkt man schon, da ist eine andere Stabilität da. Das funktioniert einfach alles defensiv besser. Man hat es aber geschafft, dabei diese offensiv Idee, die man hat, nicht zu vernachlässigen. Und ich glaube, da ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, dass man mit Martijn Kars jetzt einen Stürmer im Kader hat, der diese Bezeichnung tatsächlich auch verdient. Also der Bengel, der macht unheimlich Spaß und ich hoffe, dass wir den nicht schon wieder nächsten Sommer verlieren, weil der gerade, glaube ich, sich schon auf den Zettel von einem anderen Verein spielt. Und das sind so Kleinigkeiten gewesen, die man angepasst hat. Man hat taktisch auch ein bisschen was verändert. Man ist nicht mehr, man spielt nicht mehr so dieses ganz krasse Offensiv-Harakiri. Und ich glaube, das sind alles so Kleinigkeiten, die dazu beigetragen haben. Und natürlich auch, die Spieler sind erfahrener. Sie sind jetzt wieder, haben jetzt wieder ein Jahr 2. Liga gespielt. Und das trägt natürlich dann alles dazu bei, dass man dann eben jetzt auch insgesamt stabiler sich darstellt, als das letzte Saisonort der Phalmer.
Denn ich hatte mir auch diese Frage gestellt, hat Christian Tietz etwas angepasst oder läuft einfach mal alles in seinem Sinne? Das kann man nicht in der Seite erkennen. Oder die war halt vielleicht in der Mitte. Ich habe mir dann nämlich auch mal die Statistik angekriegt, vor allen Dingen mit Ball. Man hat dann weiterhin den höchsten Ballbesitz der Liga. Auch ist sehr gut, was hohen Ballbesitz angeht. Also man hat den nicht nur zwischen den Inverteidigern, sondern in hohen Räumen. Man hat die drittigste Passquote, die viertmeisten Tore, gleichzeitig die wenigsten Flanken, aber die zweitmeisten Dribblings. Also auch da ist nach wie vor diese Dribbler-Eigenschaft drin. Liegt das daran, dass, wie gesagt, jetzt mit Doris Kahrs beispielsweise erwähnt, dass die Spieler jetzt noch mehr verinnerlicht haben, was Christian Tietz will? Oder hast du das Gefühl, dass er sich auch ein Stück weit mit Ball irgendwie verändert hat? Weil die Statistiken würden es jetzt erstmal nicht hergeben. Aber du guckst ja jedes Spiel. Das ist ja wichtiger als jede Zahl.
Ich glaube schon, dass das Großteil doch an den Spielern liegt. Christian Tietz hat so viel gerade im Offensivspiel nicht verändert. Es ist immer noch hohes Pressing, hohes Anlaufen, den Gegner früh stressen und zu Ball gewinnen oder zu Ballverlusten in dem Fall dann zwingen und dann selbst über die Ballgewinne dann vorne zu versuchen, schnell zu Abschlüssen zu kommen. Im eigenen Ballbesitz ist es dann viel dieses wirklich Ball laufen lassen. Wie du schon sagst, wenig flanken. Das sieht man auch daran. Martin Kahrs ist jetzt auch kein Stürmer, der in seinen Stationen vorher mit Kopfaltoren geglänzt hat. Auch er, einer, der sehr, sehr stark am Fuß ist. Aber eben mit seinen 1.80 auch jetzt nicht unbedingt das gerade Maß für einen Stürmer ist, wenn man das mal so sagen kann. Und das sieht man ja auch daran, dass Christian Tietz gern auf den Außenpositionen mit inversen Spielern spielt. Also auf der linken Außenbahn Rechtsfüße zu stehen hat und dann auf der rechten Außenbahn Linksfüße, die dann eben mit ihren starken Dribblings immer in die Mitte ziehen und so natürlich den Gegner vor eine andere Herausforderung stellen. Ist natürlich dann auch wieder das Problem, wenn man sich als Gegner dort relativ gut darauf einstellt und man es schafft, so diese erste Pressing-Linie von uns zu überspielen, entstehen natürlich auch sehr, sehr große Räume für den Gegner. Das ist natürlich immer das Risiko, was wir dabei haben. Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was diese Saison sich ein bisschen verändert hat zur letzten Saison, dass wir es schaffen, in der Restverteidigung diese Räume besser zu schließen. Und das war eben letzte Saison ein großes Problem. Da haben wir uns dann doch auch oft genau in diesen Räumen überlaufen lassen und haben den Gegner eben genau da eben diese Möglichkeiten geschenkt, um dann zu relativ einfachen Toren auch zu kommen. Und das ist weg. Was immer noch da ist, leider Gottes, ist so ein bisschen so diese individuelle Fehleranfälligkeit. Ich sage da nur, das Spiel gegen Fürth, wo wir es ja tatsächlich geschafft haben. Ich glaube, auch in zehn Jahren werden beide Mannschaften noch in einem Saisonrückblick auftauchen, dass man da schafft, aus dem Spiel heraus zweimal solche Handspiele zu fabrizieren. Das ist wirklich grandios. Ich glaube, da haben wir wirklich Geschichte geschrieben, Fürth und wir. Mal gucken, wenn wir das noch abstellen können.
Das ist ja auch Thema. Genau. Wie würdest du denn die Transferphase im Sommer bewerten? Denn da konnte man insofern mit Säugetrauf gucken, als dass Magdeburg mit El-Fatli ja auch einen wirklichen Säugenspieler verloren hatte.
Also ich denke, von dem, was man geholt hat, war es, finde ich, die beste Transferphase von Odoamne Schork bis jetzt. Gerade die angesprochenen Spiele, die du schon genannt hast, Matthiessen, der dann sofort Stammspieler geworden ist, Martijn Kars, der sofort Stammspieler geworden ist, Musande, der sofort Stammspieler geworden ist, Ney Zayn, der am Anfang der Saison gespielt hat, Livan Burcu, der auch Anfangs der Saison gespielt hat. Also da sieht man schon, da hat sich auch was verändert im Vergleich zur letzten Saison. Wenn man da sieht, da war die Startelf, glaube ich, ein Neuling, der Rest war vom Vorjahr und jetzt hatten wir, glaube ich, in der Startelf vier Neue. Und da sieht man dann schon auch, dass da, ja, dass da auch was passiert ist. Musste auch passieren, mussten die Qualität auch ein bisschen, es musste einfach auch was passieren. Und gerade im Sturm, Matalj Kars, also der Junge, der macht einfach Spaß. Und das ist, da hat man wirklich einen geholt. Absoluter Glückstreffer, super, super Spieler, auch ein toller Typ so von seiner Art. Und bei El Fadli, bin ich persönlich immer noch der Meinung, da hätte ich ganz gern, wenn man da im Winter vielleicht doch noch einen klaren Sechser holt, weil das hat man jetzt aufgefangen mit Jean-Yves Gournay, der letzte Saison bei uns viel in der Innenverteilung gespielt hat, wenn er nicht verletzt war. Und ich bin der Meinung, da sollten wir vielleicht auch noch mal im Winter gucken, dass man da noch einen klaren Sechser doch noch mal holt, weil ich finde, den El Fadli-Abgang, den konnte man noch nicht ganz so ersetzen, auch wenn die Tabellensituation natürlich was anderes aussagt.
Was ist denn, ich habe mich nach diesem Saisonstart von Magdeburg auch ein Stück weit gefragt, was ist denn jetzt die Erwartungshaltung für diese Saison und wo will Magdeburg so mittelfristig hin? Was soll, gibt es da auch vom Verein aus irgendwie, es gibt ja oft diese, in der 2. Liga kann man eigentlich ein Trinkspiel draus machen, ist dieses Thema, wir wollen zu Top 25 der Deutschlands gehören, dieses typische Top-Feld in der 2. Liga, aber auch gerne mit Blick nach oben. Magdeburg ist ja nun auch schon ein paar Jahre in der 2. Liga dabei, ist jetzt das dritte Jahr in Folge?
Dritte, ja, vierte insgesamt.
Wie will man sich da entwickeln? Gibt es da einen langfristigen Plan, der den Fans und Mitgliedern schon mal präsentiert wurde?
Also ich hoffe, dass es einen gibt. Präsentiert wurde da allerdings noch nichts. Ich bin immer freund davon, also ich wäre freund davon, zu sagen, wir wollen mehr Punkte holen als in der vergangenen Saison. Die Platzierung spielt dann grundsätzlich erstmal keine Rolle, aber wenn man mehr Punkte holt, hat man sich ja grundsätzlich erstmal verbessert. Man hat dieses Jahr gar nichts gesagt. Letzte Saison ist ja Othmar Schork in die Saison gegangen mit der Aussage, wir wollen eine sorgenfreie Saison spielen. Ich glaube, wenn man auf die Rückgründe guckt, die war alles andere als sorgenfrei. Diese Saison kann man das durchaus sagen bis jetzt. Ich meine, wir haben immer einen guten Abstand nach unten seit dem dritten, vierten Spieltag. Jetzt gerade zweistellige Punkte nach unten vorsprungen, das ist gut einstellig, das ist super. Wenn es so bleibt, alles gut. Also in meinem Umfeld hier ist es so, wie gesagt, jeder, das sind bis jetzt 16 Punkte für den Klassenerhalt, nicht mehr und nicht weniger. Und träumen sollen hier andere. Also ich glaube, es ging ja hier schon ein bisschen, so ein bisschen schon wieder los, medial auch. Da ist der FCM aufstiegsreif und da sage ich mir mal Leute, nee, lass doch diesen Quatsch einfach sein. Lass uns erst mal 40 Punkte holen und dann gucken wir weiter. Man hat letzte Saison gesehen, wie schwer das werden kann, wenn du dann in eine Rückrunde gerätst, in der gar nichts mehr läuft. Und von daher schön den Ball flach halten, so weitermachen, wie wir das bis jetzt machen. Und diese Punkte, die wir haben, sind, glaube ich, für mich auf jeden Fall und auch in meinem Umfeld alles Punkte gegen Klassen erhält. Und was da jetzt in den nächsten Jahren kommt, also ich persönlich würde mich freuen, wenn wir es hier in Magdeburg schaffen, in den nächsten drei bis fünf Jahren einfach ein Zweitliches zu sein, der keine Abstiegssorgen hat und vielleicht dann in drei, vier, fünf Jahren auch mal ein bisschen nach oben schielen kann in Richtung der ersten 5, 6, 7 Plätze. Das wäre für mich eine super Entwicklung.
Wie ist denn die Stimmung in der Region? Insofern, wenn man von dem konstrukt in der ersten Liga absieht, ist der 1. FC Magdeburg der erfolgreichste Ostverein. Hat man das Gefühl, dass man da irgendwie auch Zulauf bekommt? Oder ist das alles so in Stein gemeißelt, die Fanlager in den Regionen, dass es relativ gleichbleibend ist?
Jetzt hast du Unionen noch vergessen, kann ich als Hattana auch nachvollziehen.
Das ist vollkommen korrekt, ja.
Und ja, das ist mir persönlich eigentlich völlig egal. Also ich bin aus diesem Ostwestdenken ein bisschen raus. Ob wir da jetzt 2. Beste oder 3. Beste Ostklubs sind, ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal. Wichtig ist, dass man, ich freue mich darüber, dass wir endlich mal gegen Vereine und das auch vermehrt spielen, gegen die wir viele viele viele viele Jahre nicht spielen durften, aufgrund von Situationen, die eben lange lange vorbei sind. Und deswegen, also mir bedeutet das nicht, wichtig ist für mich, dass wir diesen Sprung geschafft haben, endlich in diese 2. Liga und dass wir diese Position auch halten. Und vielleicht sogar auch mal demnächst, also mittelfristig, jetzt nicht die Saison, mittelfristig vielleicht sogar mal nach oben ausrutschen, was glaube ich auch eine schöne Sache wäre. Und ich glaube, fentechnisch hat sich dahingehend eigentlich nicht viel verändert. Das ist hier so diese Region, dass ich glaube, du hast dann auch zu viel Konkurrenz im Umfeld. Wenn du nach Richtung Westen guckst, hast du Hannover-Braunschweig. Wenn du Richtung Norden guckst, dann Rostock, Richtung Osten hast du dann die Berliner. Also ich glaube, da ist es gut, Richtung Süden kommt lange nichts bis nach Bayern runter. Aber ansonsten glaube ich, da wird sich auch zukünftig nicht viel verändern.
Ich habe die Info nicht gefunden. Gibt es eine Info darüber, wie lange Christian Titz Vertrag in Magdeburg läuft?
Ne, seit zwei, drei Jahren kommuniziert das der Verein leider nicht mehr. Da man letzte Saison, ich denke mal ein, zwei Jahre, also ich denke mal diese Saison auf jeden Fall, ja klar, sonst wäre er nicht da, das ist blöd. Und ich würde mal sagen, nächste Saison auch noch. Es ist aber wirklich rein ins Blaue, also das weiß keiner, weil das nicht mehr kommuniziert wird.
Wie ist denn, also dass Christian Titz der Erfolgstrainer Magdeburgs ist, steht ja fest, er hat den Verein aus der 3. Liga in die 2. geführt und etabliert, lässt spektakulären Fußball spielen. Aber wie wird er auch rein menschlich im Verein wahrgenommen? Magdeburg ist ja wie gesagt auch ein großer Traditionsverein, da sehnt man sich oft nach den altmodischen Typen. Christian Titz nämlich als ein Mann der leiseren Worte war, wie ist so sein quasi zwischenmenschliche Standing im Verein?
Das ist eine gute Frage, aber damit habe ich mir persönlich nie so richtig Gedanken gemacht. Also er ist schon glaube ich aufgrund seiner Art, eben wie du schon sagst, er ist ein ruhigerer Typ, ist er glaube ich auch jetzt nicht unbeliebt. Er ist ja schon auch jemand, der aufgrund der Geschichte mit seinem Sohn, er hat ja dann einen Verein gegründet für Heumakinder, und da ist er sehr, sehr aktiv auch, hat er hier im Umfeld auch schon die ein oder andere Spenderaktion dafür mit organisiert und auch durchgeführt. Also das nimmt man schon wahr, dass er ja schon auch ein eher sozial eingestellter Typ ist. Aber ansonsten habe ich mich damit jetzt eigentlich weniger befasst, was da so gehauen und gestochen ist. Ich nehme ihn da eigentlich mehr als Trainer war, als Typ.
Als wirklicher Fußballlehrer. Ein Thema, was mir in der Vorbereitung auch über den Weg gekommen ist und was ich auch schon seit ein paar Jahren immer so nebenbei verfolge, ist die Ansiedlung Intels in Magdeburg. Denn Intel ist ja auch Sponsor sowohl bei Magdeburger Fußball als auch Handballverein. Allerdings ist es ja so, dass sich die Ansiedlung nun verzögert, damit auch Milliardeninvestitionen in Magdeburg. Es bleiben ja sogar Zweifel, wenn man mit dir ein bisschen durchliest, ob das Werk jemals entsteht. Nimmst du da eine gewisse Nervosität rund um den Verein war? Und was hätte das der Stadt, der Region bedeutet?
Also Nervosität gar nicht. Also es gibt ja jetzt ein Vertrag, es gibt wohl dieses Saisonvertrag, dass man da Technologie-Partner ist. Wir haben ja unter anderem durch Intel gesponsert auch zwei neue Leinwände bekommen im Stadion. Also man ist da eher, das war so das, was man gehört hat, Intel ist eher so Technologie-Partner, machen da so, unterstützen da so ein bisschen. Beim SCM, also beim Handball-Club, ist es wohl auch so, dass man da so ein bisschen auf dieser Ebene was macht. Von daher glaube ich jetzt nicht, dass das große Auswirkungen, ich glaube da ist auch jetzt keiner nervös, wenn das jetzt, wie das dann weitergeht, denke ich nicht. Also dafür sind wir in Magdeburg, glaube ich auch. Was das Thema Sponsoren aufgeht, ist ja auch ein bisschen anders, man ist ja anders aufgestellt. Man hat ja nicht den einen oder die zwei Großsponsoren, man hat viele, viele kleine Sponsoren, mittlere Sponsoren, die dieses ganze Sponsoring-Feld aufbauen und ich glaube, das ist auch ganz gut so. Deswegen wird das jetzt auch nicht so wehtun, was da jetzt auch immer nächstes Jahr passiert. Also wird man dann sehen und das jetzt mit Intel, ja klar, natürlich hat das schon für eine Euphorie gesorgt in der Region, ganz klar. Ich meine, das ist nun mal schon was, wenn dann so ein Weltkonzern sagt, hier, ich baue da jetzt bei euch ein Werk, warum auch immer, warum wir uns nichts vormachen, da fließen ja auch bestimmte Sachen auch im Hintergrund, die da sicherlich auch für Intel diese Entscheidung ein bisschen erleichtert haben. Aber da darf man natürlich gespannt sein, was dann in zwei Jahren passiert. Wenn dann die zwei Jahre rum sind, die man sich jetzt gesagt hat, man legt das erstmal auf Eis, man ist da schon gespannt, hier was da passiert und inwieweit das dann auch Einfluss auf die Sponsorenlandschaft im Bereich Sport haben kann, das wird man dann sehen. Aber ich glaube, das wird jetzt erstmal ad hoc keine großen Auswirkungen haben.
Du hast die Sponsorenlandschaft jetzt eben auch angesprochen. Wie ist denn die Lage dahingehend? Wie ist Magdeburg, also der 1. FC Magdeburg, generell wirtschaftlich aufgestellt? Wie sicher steht man da jetzt auch im 3. Zweitliga?
Ja super. Also ich glaube, finanziell kann man schon so sagen, ohne da jetzt arrogant klingen zu wollen, wir sind glaube ich einer der gesündesten Vereine, die es in Deutschland gibt, was das finanzielle angeht. Das ging ja schon, aber das ist natürlich auch eine Geschichte, das ist eine Geschichte, die ging natürlich auch schon viel früher los. 2015 mit dem Aufstieg in die 3. Liga damals, das war so dieser Schlüsselmoment, der dann auch dafür gesorgt hat, dass das eben alles so läuft. Wenn man sich überlegt, der damalige Finanzchef hat es geschafft, hier in der Regionalliga einen Verein zu entschuldigen. Also wir haben in der Regionalliga…
Wie ist das gelungen?
Durch sehr, sehr gute Arbeit. Ich würde sagen, wie gesagt, im Sponsoringbereich viele kleine Sponsoren reingeholt, die dann eben das gemacht haben, wo dann 10, 20 Sponsoren den Effekt haben, den vielleicht bei einem vergleichbaren Verein dann eine oder zwei Sponsoren haben.
Okay.
Und so hat man dann hier und natürlich auch mit sehr, sehr guter finanzieller Arbeit. Dann kam natürlich auch dazu, muss man eben auch sagen, der Zuschauerschnitt ging dann von Jahr zu Jahr nach oben. Man hatte Zuschauereinnahmen gerade in der dritten Liga, die nicht viele Vereine, glaube ich, haben. Und das hat natürlich eine große, große Rolle gespielt. Und das führt man jetzt in der zweiten Liga fort. Und man steht finanziell wirklich sehr, sehr gut da. Also wenn man da jetzt auf die Mückle-Versammlung im letzten Jahr guckt, da kann man schon auch als Mückle und als Fernseher sehr stolz drauf sein, was hier finanziell gearbeitet wird. Also hier macht keiner Harakiri. Hier wird keiner irgendwie sagen, wir hauen jetzt hier 5 Millionen raus, um irgendwie ein Klassenlager zu schaffen. Also man macht das hier wirklich alles mit Bedacht und hat da wirklich auch aus Phasen, die wir hier im Verein hatten, gerade Anfang der 2000er mussten, hatten wir auch eine Insolvenz. Und das will man auch als fändlich normaler Leben, sowas. Und von daher ist das einfach eine super Arbeit, die man hier macht. Und das darf gern so weitergehen.
Ich sehe auch gerade die Zahlen, wo ihr über die Zahlen sprecht. Es gibt ja diesen Geschäftsabfluss für die Finanzzahlen der 2. Bundesliga für die aktuelle Saison. Das sind natürlich Zahlen aus der Vergangenheit.
Richtig.
Aber es ist Magdeburg ganz weit im Plus dabei, muss man sagen. Und das ist dann ein gesundes Fundament, wo du vielleicht auch mal einen Abstieg, den ihr wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht mehr haben werdet, weil ihr gerade sehr weit davon weg seid. Aber genau, das ist ja eben genau das Polster, was du dir aufbauen musst. Und Heidenheim hat es doch genauso gemacht. Heidenheim, der beste Verein in Deutschland seit den letzten 20 Jahren, weil mit wenig Mitteln, Konstitut. Also jedes Jahr immer wieder genau das, was du sagst, ist Thomas Schritt für Schritt am Ende der Saison ein Stück besser. Und jetzt muss man sagen, es ist respektvoll, wenn man dann genau die Finanzen noch im Blick hat. Weil manche fällen dann hier aus und sagen, okay, jetzt müssen wir aber richtig Gas geben.
Man muss aber glaube ich auch dazu sein, und das gehört zur Wahrheit ja auch dazu. Du konntest dich natürlich auch so entwickeln, weil du eben von unten mit strukturen, ich sag mal mit kleinen strukturen, dich nach oben entwickeln konntest. Wenn du jetzt so Vereine hast wie Kaiserslautern damals oder jetzt auch wie Schalke, du kommst ja mit einem ganz anderen Fundament in diese Liga. Und wenn es jetzt Schalke wirklich in die dritte Liga herunterruppen sollte, Kaiserslautern hat es ja auch durchgemacht. Man hat ja gesehen, was das für diese Clubs heißt. Und das ist natürlich schon ein Vorteil gewesen. Wir kamen aus einer Situation, wo wir von den strukturen natürlich auch anders arbeiten konnten. Also wir hatten ganz andere strukturen. Kann man gar nicht miteinander vergleichen. Also ich würde jetzt niemals ins Zeigefinger gehen und sagen, die in Schalke, die machen schlechte Finanzarbeit, weil man es gar nicht miteinander vergleichen kann mit unserer Situation. Also wir hatten da schon den Vorteil, dass wir mit strukturen als Viertligist hochgekommen sind und das peu à peu ausbauen können. Und das aber eben auch so wächst, dass es in einem gesunden Maß wächst. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch das Entscheidende dabei.
Ja, ich glaube generell in Magdeburg war es richtig gut, dass genau On-Point Stadt, Stadion, Verein, Fans zusammen was gemacht haben. Das Stadion stand, es wurden die strukturen entwickelt und dadurch– natürlich hattet ihr auch Glück mit guten Trainern, muss man auch sagen– guten Spielern, gute Scouting. War richtig gut. Liga war ja für euch größtenteils ja nicht das Problem.
Die war eine Erfolgsschichte.
Genau. Außer, dass ihr Münster das erste Mal im Gästeblog nass geworden seid, weil es keine Überdachung gab. Das weiß ich noch. Das hat ja Alex mir gesagt. Jedenfalls habt ihr euch dann aber eben genau in der 2. Liga etabliert und das ist schon ein Riesenschritt mit einer guten Finanzlage. Das ist Wahnsinn.
Blickt man da auch ein bisschen– Sven Preußen Münster hat es ja genau andersrum gemacht– einfach hau ruck, wir gehen sofort durch in die 2. Liga. Da gibt es gar nicht mit kontinuierlich, sondern Attacke. Man hat es nicht so geplant logischerweise. Aber wie blickst du denn da, siehst du da in irgendeiner Weise Parallelen? Ich glaube schon, dass unter Peter Niemeyer und Co. auch eher ruhig und kontinuierlich gearbeitet wurde. Also sieht man dann vielleicht auch an Magdeburg, wo es dann hingehen kann, wenn man da demütig bleibt?
Also ich würde jetzt absolut keine Parallel zu Magdeburg ziehen. Ich weiß noch, als ich zu Gast war in Magdeburg und ich mein eigenes Wort im Gästenblock nicht gehört habe, weil die Jungs so laut waren, das war dieses Spiel, wo alle drei Tribünen damals mitgemacht haben und so weiter. Da gibt es auch YouTube-Videos ohne Ende. Das war die 2. Liga. Man schaut natürlich auf gewisse Vereine drauf, aber Magdeburg war jetzt nie irgendwie ein Thema. Bei mir im generellen Kreis und so, wie kann man das machen? Was unser Glück war, war eben der Abstieg.
Das sagt man auch selten. Unser Glück war der Abstieg.
Ja, der war bitter in der Corona-Zeit. Ohne Fans. Du steigst einfach ab und dann stehen da die 22 Jungs auf dem Platz. Du kannst dich ja nicht verabschieden. Du kannst ja nichts machen. Es war ja nichts möglich. Unser Glück war aber eben genau, wir haben einen Marcel Hoffmeier im Kader gehabt. Der spielt jetzt bei Paderborn. Seit drei Jahren, glaube ich, 2. Liga. Rambo, Remberg, Nikolaj Remberg. Kiel, 1. Liga. Letzte Saison noch mit denen aufgestiegen. Ja, also das waren Spieler, die wir dadurch dann auch hochziehen konnten. Das war geschuldet natürlich der Situation. Du hast kein Geld. Du machst irgendwas, du baust es auf. Deswegen sage ich jedem Duisburger Fan gerade, das kann für euch eine Chance sein. Nur Duisburg setzt sich auf Jugend, sondern hat sich als eingekauft. Und wir haben damals auf Jugend gesetzt. Und dann haben sich die Spieler entwickelt. Wir haben denen eine Chance gegeben. Das Problem meiner Geschichte ist, Münster war halt Corona-Zeit. Abstieg, Neuaufbau, Glück mit Niemeyer. Absolut. Absolutes Glück mit Niemeyer. Die mussten wir jetzt auch kompensieren. Aber du kannst dann nicht Magdeburg als Vorbild nehmen, weil das Stadion, was sie haben, das haben wir nicht.
Definitiv ein wichtiger Punkt. Und eigentlich ist die Überleitung zu Preußen Münster und dem Thema 2 dieser Sendung quasi gebaut. Trotzdem möchte ich, Thomas, dich einmal noch fragen, gibt es aktuell Themen, vielleicht auch außerhalb des Platzes, die FCM-Fans in irgendeiner Weise beschäftigen? Oder ist man gerade einfach glücklich und zufrieden?
Also rein sportlich, glaube ich, sind wir sehr, sehr zufrieden. Mein Tabellenplatz ist, glaube ich, auch erstmal egal. Wichtig sind die Punkte und die Abstand, die wir nach unten haben. Da ist mir jetzt egal, ob wir 2. oder 4. oder 8. sind. Ansonsten Themen, ich meine, es jährt sich jetzt. Wir haben jetzt wieder einen Gedenktag am kommenden Wochenende. Es ist heute bekannt gegeben worden. Man hat dort eine Möglichkeit gegeben, um da gedenken zu. 2000, es gab ja da diesen Vorfall mit Hannes, der da ums Leben gekommen ist, nach Auseinandersetzungen in einem Zug mit Fans hier aus dem Süden von uns, der Verein da. Und da hat man jetzt so ein bisschen so eine Gedenkmöglichkeit geschaffen. Das wird ganz gut. Da wird jetzt am Wochenende auch nochmal von den Ultras und auch von Fanrat und Verein, jemanden, um ein bisschen was dazu zu sagen. Das hat man damals etabliert, unter unserem ehemaligen Präsidenten Peter Fechner hat man das damals schon etabliert. Und das führt man jetzt weiter. Das ist eine schöne Sache. Leider Gottes ein schlimmer Grund, der dafür daherhalten musste, dass sowas passiert. Aber an sich eine schöne Sache, dass man da auch immer wieder nochmal drauf guckt und sagt, hier Leute, es ist letzten Endes doch nur Fußball. Und ja, das ist so das, was jetzt gerade so ein bisschen ist. Aber ansonsten gibt es da jetzt relativ wenig, was hier in Magdeburg zumindest nach meinem Wissen im Umfeld irgendwie wichtig wäre.
Ruhige Zeiten in großen Traditionsvereinen, das gibt es nicht so oft. Deswegen können wir das gerne genauso stehen lassen. Dann müssen wir gar nichts aufmachen, was es nicht gibt. Und gehen dann weiter zu Sven und Preußen Münster. Zwei Aufstieg in Folge von der Regionalliga direkt in die 2. Liga. Sven, beschreib uns diese verrückte Reise gerne einmal in Kurzform. Wie war das möglich? Und was waren die entscheidenden Faktoren für die 2. Liga Rückkehr nach 33 Jahren?
Also kurz vor der Regionalliga war es dann fertig. Nachdem Dortmund hochgegangen ist, wir dann gegen Essen gegen ein Torverhältnis. Essen hatte damals ja ein 11 zu 0 gegen Ueddingen. Und das war das Torverhältnis. Dann werden wir auch schon eine Saison vorher hochgegangen. Gut, dann war es dann in der dritten Saison, Regionalliga West, war es dann eigentlich fertig. Du hattest keinen richtigen Konkurrenten. Du hast dich aufgebaut, eben genau mit Niemeyer im sportlichen Bereich. Es war sehr gut, es war sehr ruhig. Es ist nichts nach außen gedrungen. Es war eine ruhige Arbeit, was ich so beim Verein schon ewig nicht mehr mitbekommen habe, weil sonst waren irgendwie irgendwelche Lex immer zu hören, lesen, sehen, wie auch immer. Ja, dann 3. Liga. Ja, gut, kommst an. Spielst 0-0 am ersten Spieltag gegen Dortmund. Denkst du dir auch schon, du hättest ja schon gewinnen müssen. Verlierst die Derbys gegen Essen und Bielefeld in der Hinrunde. Bitter. Ja, stehst irgendwie gesund. Zufrieden. Ich sag mal, vor dem letzten Spieltag der Hinrunde. Man muss dir sagen, wir hatten ja noch das Nachholspiel mit Dortmund. Aber stehst eigentlich ganz gut da, so im Mittelfeld. Und dann zündest du in der Regionalliga West in der Rückrunde und ballast ein Spiel nach dem anderen weg. Und manche Spiele kann ich bis heute nicht erklären, warum wir sie gewonnen haben. Also gegen Dresden in der dritten Liga, das wird mir immer in Erinnerung bleiben. Dresden total dominant, aber du gewinnst 1-0. Ja, und am Ende ziehen wir das dann. Oder du verlierst nicht in Köln, gegen Viktoria Köln. 1-0 zurück, 2-0 zurück, 3-1 war es sogar. Und dann gewinnst du am Ende in Viktoria Köln, bei Viktoria Köln 5-3. Und genau da stand ich im Block und dachte mir, jetzt geht alles. Dann fährst du in ein Affärl, alle mit Trikot. Da war jeder Preußisch-Fan mit Trikot. Keiner neutral oder sowas. Das war vorher angekündigt. Und ja, verlierst du. Und machst dann eben den Aufstieg zu Hause. Klar, Wunderbärchen. Aber so eine Story kannst du nicht schreiben. Also, die kannst du nicht planen. Das war Glück, weil Dresden, Regensburg, nicht mehr performt haben nach der Hinrunde. Die standen ja, ich glaube, es waren 20 Punkte vor uns, Regensburg. Oder Dresden, ich weiß nicht. Also, es war ein Riesenabstand. Ja, aber wir haben das Spiel geholt. Und das kannst du aber nicht beschreiben. Interessant ist es natürlich in der dritten Liga, dass es in den letzten Jahren öfter vorgekommen ist, dass Aufsteiger performt haben, weil sie eben genau mit ihrer Manpower zusammenbleiben. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Schlüssel, das in Folge ist, dass du die Key-Spieler zusammenhältst, aber das gleich zwei so durchmarschieren. Sehr, sehr spannend.
Stimmt, Ulm auch direkt durch. Aber liegt das dann vielleicht auch daran, dass einfach das Gefälle zwischen vierter und dritter Liga nicht so groß ist wie zwischen der dritten und der zweiten? Also, dass du auch mit den Mannschaften, die oben in einer Regionalliga mitspielen, diese dann gewinnen, auch realistische Chancen hast, mit diesem Momentum heraus dann in der dritten Liga auch zu performen, weil einfach die Qualitätsunterschiede gar nicht so groß sind?
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen das Problem von den Regionalligen selber. Wenn man die Regionalliga West nimmt, dann hat man Köln 2 da drin, Schalke 2. Man hat viele Zweitmannschaften dabei. Das ist ein ganz anderer Tenor, als was du in Nord-Nord-Ost in Süd hast. Ich finde die bayerische Staffel in der Regionalliga sehr mau, weil die Vereine schnell durchgehen. Weil du im Grunde genommen ein großes Potenzial hast mit Bayern, Nürnberg usw. Da ist sehr, sehr viel dabei. Aber die zweiten Mannschaften selber haben halt mal performt. Und dann bauen sie sehr schnell ab. Und in der West-Staffel hast du halt ein hohes Niveau bei eben Roport. Viele Menschen, viele Spieler usw. Das finde ich schon sehr interessant. Und dann hast du natürlich ein großes Problem mit Schalke 2, mit Köln 2, Gladbach 2, viele zweite Mannschaften, die eben genau diese Talentspieler da einsetzen. Von daher ist, glaube ich, Regionalliga West immer noch die stärkste Regionalliga. Und wir sind einfach genau mit dem Kern hochgegangen in die Wirtliga. Das hat uns viel gebracht. Wir waren auch sehr verletzungsfrei und konnten Remberg und T-Club kompensieren. So, das war der Erfolg dann mit der geschlossenen Mannschaftsleistung, am Ende in der Liga anzukommen, dann hochzugehen. Aber auch mit viel Glück, man muss auch sagen. Wir haben auch Spiele gezogen, die wir nie hätten gewinnen können. Also, da muss man auch so ehrlich sein.
Oder man hatte einfach einen fantastischen Trainer, der genau diese Spiele trotzdem gezogen hat. Trainer Sascha Hildmann steht jetzt seit dem 1. Januar 2020 an der Münsteraner Seitendinie, was auch für einen Trainer eine wirklich lange Zeit heutzutage ist. Er hat die Erfolgsgeschichte dementsprechend maßgeblich geprägt. Was ist Hildmann für ein Typ? Was macht ihn aus? Und warum passt er so gut nach Münster?
Hildmann ist sehr extrovertiert, sehr Kumpeltyp, geht auf die Lok zu, mag es natürlich auch so ein bisschen, das so ein bisschen zu leben, wenn der Erfolg da ist. Stellt sich aber auch immer hinter die Mannschaft, ist immer ein Motivator, einer, der dich anspornet. Also selbst wenn du in der Ecke liegst, der holt dich raus, der zieht dich raus. Und da wollen wir ja hinkommen. Also das ist glaube ich auch die Stärke gewesen in der 3. Liga. Die Mannschaft war immer von der Motivation, von dem Kopf her immer gut eingestellt. Marschieren, marschieren, marschieren. In der 3. Liga konntest du aber dieses rohe Pressing noch machen. In der 2. Liga sagt z.B. Thomas, wenn wir jetzt im Magdeburg spielen oder bei uns, da wären wir gerne eingeladen. Das kannst du nicht mehr so fahren, wie du das in der Regionalliga West gemacht hast. In der 3. Liga schon ein bisschen weniger. Wir haben es in der 2. Liga versucht und haben auch bitter kassiert. Das ist so dieser Ankommen-Prozess. Es funktioniert nicht mehr so, wie du es haben kannst. Natürlich mit den Verletzungen, die wir jetzt haben. Wir haben jetzt vier Langzeitverletzte, die uns auch wirklich zurückwerfen. Aber da musst du hin. Das System muss sich anpassen. Und hilft man es aber trotzdem, ich sage mal, ein Motivationsfaktor.
Du hast es angesprochen, den Saisonstart. Jetzt hat man sechs Punkte nach neun Spielen. Wie ist dieser Saisonstart für Münster denn gelaufen? Hast du das Gefühl, dass dieser Prozess, in der 2. Liga anzukommen, zumindest schon mal gestartet ist? Oder findet sich die Mannschaft da teilweise doch noch ein bisschen in Schockstarre?
Also hätten wir uns jetzt vor drei Wochen getroffen, hätte ich gesagt, okay, wir werden angekommen. Die letzten beiden Partien waren so ein bisschen ernüchternd. Aber wir hatten gute Spiele gegen Lautern, da kriegst du halt in der letzten Ecke das Tor, da hättest du einen Punkt mitgenommen. Gegen Hannover waren wir überlegen, zu Hause. Spielen wir 0-0. In Nürnberg führst du… Ja, es reicht momentan einfach nicht für 90 Minuten. Und im Moment haben wir halt so, ich sag mal, die Differenz zwischen 1. und 2. Halbzeit. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt gerade Fitness ist. Wir hatten jetzt Nimet, der bei Ungarn, bei der Nationalsport von der U21 war. Und wir hatten Grodowski, den greifenden Effekt. Die wurden reingeschmissen im letzten Spiel gegen Ebersberg. Und irgendwie vorne war schon gar nichts mehr. Fitness. Keine Ahnung. Aber wir haben halt sozusagen um den Ausgleichstreffer gebettelt und waren am Ende froh, einen Punkt mitzunehmen. Und Preußen Münster hat eben ausgezeichnet in der Regionalliga West-Aufstiegssaison und in der dritten Liga die Heimstärke. Alle Punkte haben wir eigentlich heim gemacht. In der dritten Liga haben wir glaube ich ein oder zwei Spiele verloren. Und wir haben sehr viele gewonnen. Und das kriegen wir gerade nicht auf den Platz. Also wir haben gute Spiele gehabt. Wir hatten gute Szenen, wir hatten gute Halbzeiten, auch gegen Hamburg. Aber dann kommt auch wieder zum anderen zum Tragen, dass wir auch Lehrgeld bezahlen in der Liga. Also Ankommen, Standardsituation, blöd verteidigt, Kontersituation, scheiße verteidigt, ins offene Messer laufen und so weiter. Das ist der Prozess, den wir noch nicht haben. Deswegen war jetzt ein Hardcore-Cut gegen Elbersberg, wo einfach mal komplett umgestellt worden ist, mehr defensiv in der Prämisse war. Und das sah auch ganz gut aus, aber über 90 Minuten mit dem Wechsel, war es dann wieder scheiße.
Scheiße ist auch, dass mit Malik Badmars der designierte Torjäger fehlt. Letztes Jahr hat er 17 Tore zum Aufstieg beigetragen, auch zum Saisonauftakt getroffen, noch in der neuen Saison. Seitdem fällt er aber mit einem Kreuzbandriss aus. Man unterbietet seinen Expected Goals-Wert um 3,35 Tore, was ja auch zeigt, man hat durchaus Torchancen, nutzt sie aber in Gänze dann nicht. Wie schwer wiegt denn dieser Auswahl? Kann man Badmars irgendwie ersetzen oder zeigen, dass das ein ganz, ganz schweres Unterfangen ist?
Es ist sehr schwierig, Preußen Münster einzuordnen, weil wir in den letzten Spielen gegen Elbersberg komplett anders gespielt haben. Sonst hatte du vorhin Lorenz mit langen Einwürfen für die Standards und auch für die Ecken. Dann hast du Lorenz rausgenommen, weil er nicht mehr in der Stadt war, dann war es der Peterhof, der hat auch die langen Einwürfe gemacht. Und gegen Elbersberg hatten wir das erste Mal nicht. Es war das erste Mal, dass wir keinen hatten, der diese langen Einwürfe machen könnte. Frank hat könnte das wahrscheinlich auch noch. Aber deswegen war das Spielziel komplett anders. Was für uns zumindest in der ersten Halbzeit sehr gut aussah, weil er spielfluss bleibt. Weil wenn du diese ganzen langen Einwürfe machst, dann wird immer irgendwie so eine Werbe… Ich weiß nicht, wie nennen sich die Dinger?
Werbebande?
Ja, Werbebanden nicht. Aber das sind ja diese Kunststoff-Dinger. Werbe-Kunststoff-Teile, die werden dann zu Seite gekickt. Und dann hängst du dann da. Und dann hast du aber wieder so eine große Unterbrechung. So, was mir gegen Eversbek aufgefallen ist, der Spielfluss war besser. In der ersten Halbzeit vor allem. In der zweiten Halbzeit hat uns Eversbek richtig reingerockt. Aber davor hatten wir halt die Spiele auf die Standards, lange Einwürfe und so weiter. Das war interessant, Möglichkeiten. Dadurch haben wir auch dann ab Spieltag fünf bis acht Tore erzielt. In Nürnberg und gegen Schalke und so weiter. Also es ist schon ein probates Mittel. Nur jetzt sind die Spiele raus. So, gegen Eversbek war keiner von den beiden Einwürfen dabei. So, das heißt, es verändert sich nochmal. Wir haben in der Defensive ein großes Problem, dass wir mit Kules, Scherda, Petov und Frenkert keinen gestammtenen Zweite-Ticker-Spieler haben. Keinen mit Erfahrung. So, da war die Defensive deswegen sehr viel defensiver gespielt gegen Elbersberg. Vielleicht zu defensiv. Und diese ganzen Sachen musst du jetzt gerade einbauen, mitnehmen, dich ausprobieren, auch wenn du in der 2. Liga nicht viel Zeit hast, die auszuprobieren. Weil du kannst dich eigentlich nur 34 Spieltage ausprobieren. Keine Ahnung, wo es hingeht. Ich war sehr angepisst, weil wir uns einfach gegen Elbersberg hinten reingestellt haben und gar nichts mehr nach vorne gemacht haben. Um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, kannst du die Ausfälle wie Badmantz, Bazzoli, Mofza mit 2. Liga-Erfahrung nicht kompensieren. Da wurde nachverpflichtet und das schaffst du nicht. Fried Jonsson ist ein interessantes Thema, aber wäre schon ein ganz anderer Spielstil.
Wie fährt denn der Gesamturteil zur Transferphase aus? Man hat ja auch beispielsweise Joschow Maes geholt, der jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal getroffen hat. Hat man da im Rahmen seiner Möglichkeiten alles getan, denn das Geld sitzt ja jetzt in Münster auch nicht locker.
Hätten wir ein paar Millionen mehr, hätte man es wahrscheinlich besser machen können. Der beste Transfer war Schenk im Tor. Der hat uns in der Liga mit Sicherheit 20 Gegentore bis Spieltag 9 verhindert. Locker.
Ich erinnere mich auf jeden Fall an eine Szene gegen Elbersberg, die er wirklich grandios hält, in der man sehr, sehr schnell nach unten geht.
Schau dir mal alle Spiele an und schau dir mal diese ganzen Szenen an, was dir alles wegfischt. Riesenverstärkung. Wie gesagt, in der Verteidigung haben wir keinen, außer Kier Kessow, auf der rechten Seite haben wir keinen 2. Liga-Profi. Frank Card hat letzte Saison noch 4. Liga bei Bocholt gespielt. Mit Hendrix hast du natürlich einen guten Group gemacht, der war wahrscheinlich günstig, hat auch Erfahrung, aber Batzolli fällt weg, der auch nicht performt hatte. Rovza mit Erfahrung fällt weg. Batzolli war letzte Saison halt eine Riesen-Base, die man im Kader hatte. Wirklich gestattener Defensivspieler. Wir haben überall nachverpflichtet, weil es dann diese Ausfälle gab. Und Friedrichshond ist kein Batman. Also wenn du einen 1,80 Spieler hast, dann der agit ist, der wuselt. Oder du hast einen Friedrichshond, der hohe Bälle halten kann. Wobei uns der, wenn er wirklich performt, wirklich weiterbringen kann, weil die langen Bälle, die wir spielen, dann von ihm auch eben verarbeitet werden können. Und das wäre dann das Konzept. Man muss ja auch von Anfang an spielen, was er jetzt das erste Mal gegen Elbersberg gemacht hat.
Wie ist denn das Saisonziel des FC Preußen Münsters? Glaubt man an den Klassenerhalt oder sagt man, wir gucken einfach, was geht? Wir sind zweimal aufgestiegen. Wir können nicht erwarten, in der Liga zu bleiben. Aber wir dürfen uns jetzt auch nicht auf dem Weg zurück kaputt machen. Wie ist da die Erwartungshaltung im und um den Verein?
Generell willst du die Klasse halten. Aber es ist schon ein Bonus, ein Luxus, wo du gerade stehst. Was du gerade hast, was du als Fan erleben kannst, das weiß auch der Verein. Das Ziel ist natürlich Klassenerhalt. Wenn du einmal an der 2. Bundesliga riechst, ich habe auch irgendwann gepostet über unser Filmmagazin, wir sind gekommen, um zu bleiben. Aber das wird ein riesen, riesen Akt. Das wird schon eine riesen Aufgabe, da die Punkte zu holen. Im Moment stehen wir auch wirklich nicht gut da. Und performenstechnisch sind wir gerade auch nicht auf On-Point. Also da waren wir schon besser in den vorherigen Spielen. Jetzt kommt ein, außer Bronschweig, sage ich jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen, die unten drinstehen, kommen dann wieder die Zickner, mit Düsseldorf, Köln und so weiter. Also Marc Schwitzky kommt auch noch.
Das wird knackig für euch die nächsten Wochen. Also ich glaube, Bronschweig wird wirklich, nochmal so ein richtiges Schlüsselspiel, glaube ich, für euch. Also ich würde sagen, da sind drei Punkte fast schon Pflicht. Wenn man dann guckt, Düsseldorf, Karlsruhe, Köln, Darmstadt, wir, Hertha, da habt ihr jetzt ein paar Wochen vor euch. Ich glaube, das leichter wird es nicht. Genau. Da solltet ihr auf jeden Fall gegen Bronschweig gewinnen. Ich glaube, die nächsten Spiele, dann wird es eher schwierig, glaube ich.
Ja, Bronschweig musst du gewinnen und dann aus den nächsten, weiß nicht, Klitzen spielen, bis Ulln fünf Punkte rausholen und dann gucken, wo du bleibst. Aber das Schöne an der zweiten Liga gerade ist, irgendwie spielen sie alle gegeneinander. Also Darmstadt haut Köln einfach 5-1 weg. Lautern haut Paderborn 3-0 weg. Okay, hätte ich vor dem Spieltag von der Performance, von der Konstellation nicht gedacht. Das führt zu Hause. 4-0 gegen Nürnberg verliert auch nicht. Von daher, ich glaube, es wird für uns eine ganz gute Liga in der 2. Bundesliga diese Saison sein, weil eben die anderen sich die Punkte nehmen. Und das wollen wir, glaube ich, auch nutzen. Aber für uns wird es ein harter Kampf. Jeder Punkt ist… also wenn da nicht Zähne in dem Oberschenkel von dem Gegner stecken, dann haben wir was falsch gemacht.
Ich habe noch so zwei Themen außerhalb des Platzes. Mit durchschnittlich knapp 3000 Auswärtsfahrern belegt Münster den siebten Platz in der 2. Liga aus dem Nichts. Das Heimstadion, auch wenn wir wissen, Umbaumaßnahmen und so weiter, ist trotzdem immer voll. Wie ist es denn dem Verein gelungen, die Fans in den Jahrzehnten, in denen er in der 3., sogar Oberliga teilweise gespielt hat, irgendwie zu halten? Wie ist da diese Identität geblieben? Denn es gibt ja auch genug andere Vereine in der Region. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute da gar nichts zu wählen hätten. Wie glaubst du, ist das irgendwie gelungen?
Das ist dem Verein nicht gelungen. Muss man einfach sagen. Der Erfolg hat es geregelt. Also die Leute, die immer da waren, die waren immer da. Und dann redest du auch vor, ich sag mal vor 20 Jahren so in etwa, gegen Dortmund 2 vor 800 Leuten. Das war damals Preußen Münster. In der Versenkung verschwunden. Und dann ist unter Marc Fascha eben der Aufstieg gelungen. Das hat schon eine erste Euphorie entfacht. Die hat der Verein aber im Marketing technisch, sag ich mal, nicht gut ausgeschlachtet. Konnte er auch nicht, weil er auch nicht die Person hatte, die dafür vielleicht präsentiert werden. Jetzt sind wir ganz anders aufgestellt. Immer noch nicht best of. Also da geht noch einiges. Wir bräuchten noch, glaube ich, drei, vier Leute im Ticketing mehr oder im Merchandising mehr. Aber der Erfolg hat es geregelt. Nicht der Verein. Also wenn sich jemand von dem Verein, was sie in gewisser Weise gut hinstellen, gut machen, gut positionieren, ja. Aber der Erfolg war die Mannschaft. Der Erfolg war der Erfolg. Und das spiegelt sich dann natürlich auch in den Zuschauerzahlen wieder. Aber gehalten? Nein. Da muss man auch so ehrlich sein. Da war so viel, ja, fehlende infrastruktur Schuld, die der Verein nicht hat, jetzt aufgebaut in vielen Dingen. Das läuft aber auch ganz gut. Da wird jetzt on point richtig geackert in Digitalisierung und so weiter. Aber der Verein selber hat nur durch die Mannschaft geschafft, dass genau diese Zuschauerzahlen zustande kommen. Und das war damals auch Marc Fascher. Dass da jemand im Ticket-Ticket sitzt oder jemand im Verein im Medienbereich sitzt oder so was. Dass der Verein da irgendwas gemacht hat. Nein.
Ich finde die Anblicke aber definitiv spannend. Denn von außen hatte ich schon zumindest das Gefühl, dass Preußen Münster lange Regionalliga spielt. Und trotzdem hatte ich immer das Gefühl, dass diese Fanbase präsent ist. Du findest in Deutschland überall Preußen Münster-Sticker. Es gibt nicht bei jedem Regionalligisten ein Fan-Scene, ein Blog, Podcasts, größere Facebook-Gruppen und so weiter. Und das fand ich interessant, dass das durchaus posiert hat weiterhin, trotz der sportlich sehr grauen Jahre von Preußen Münster. Und jetzt, wie gesagt, 3.000 Auswärtsfahrer durchschnittlich ist schon eine Wucht. Und da ist man ja sogar eine Bereicherung für die 2. Bundesliga, was bei so vielen Traditionsvereinen gar nicht selbstverständlich ist. Aber du hast das Thema infrastruktur gerade angesprochen. Das wäre mein letztes Thema gewesen. Das Stadion an der Hammerstraße, die Heimat von Preußen Münster, wird bis 2028 umgebaut und modernisiert. Wir alle sehen ja gerade diese wunderschönen grünen Bände im Stadion, die fast schon was Markantes irgendwie haben. Insgesamt soll das Stadion dann mehr als 19.000 Plätze haben. Was sind denn so die wichtigsten Eckdaten dieses Stadionprojektes, auch wirtschaftlich? Also wie stellt sich der Verein auf? Wie ist da die Stadt involviert?
Also zunächst kann ich dir sogar noch eine positive Nachricht geben, wir werden wahrscheinlich sogar 2027 fertig. Noch mal eine Information. Warum die Westkurve schon abgerissen ist, die wir hätten gut gebrauchen können mit 2.500 Gästeplätzen unüberdacht, wurde abgerissen, weil man nicht wusste, was da drunter ist. Das Stadion ist ja 1926 entstanden und viel Kriegsschutz ist da auch irgendwie noch reingewandelt. Deswegen wurde das frühzeitig abgerissen. Wir werden in der Umbauphase immer so 10.800 Plätze haben, so um die 10.500 bis 11.000 irgendwo, werden es immer dauerhaft sein. Das ist auch wichtig, eben genau um die Auflagen für den DB zu entwickeln. Du musst ja immer was nachhalten. Wir machen ja was und tun was. Die Wirtschaftlichkeit wird sein, du hast jetzt die aktuelle Tribüne. Da sind sieben bis acht Lochen, Sitzplätze, fast 3000 Stück sind es. Das sind die hochwertigen Plätze. Mehr haben wir nicht. Der Rest ist Stehplatz. Was man möchte, ist, auf der Gegenseite dann ein Gegenstück zu entwickeln, wo du mehr Lochen hast für die Anfragen, hochpreisige Plätze, die du vermarken kannst, um auch eben genau die Stehplatzplätze bedienen zu können, dass die Preise auch nicht so explodieren. Was wir auf der Ostseite haben werden, werden dann ein geschlossener Verbund von 8.700 Stehplätzen. Dann machen wir dem Magdeburger ein bisschen Konkurrenz da. Dann wird es nicht mehr so einfach, hier Münster Punkte zu holen. Genau, deswegen, es fängt jetzt mit der Westkurve an. Und dann geht die Gegend gerade los. Aber wie gesagt, in der ganzen Umbauphase sollen es halt über 10.500 Plätze sein. Ich meine, 10.800 waren jetzt so der Punkt, was man dann immer parat haben wird. Und klar, die Vermarktung ist dann halt, die Gegentribüne mit Logen auszustatten, hochpreisige Plätze anzubieten, aber halt mehr Komfort. Wir werden da das erste Standum sein, was das Mindestmaß von 1% an Rolli-Plätzen erfüllen wird. Das ist ganz wichtig. Wir werden sogar eine Kita im Stadion haben. Wir werden die Geschäftsstellen-Plätze am Stadion haben. Wir werden einen Rundumlauf haben, was andere Stadion schon haben. Das ist für uns super. Vom Gästebereich bis zum Heimbereich, weil das auch immer sehr wichtig ist. Weil es in Münster ist es lange Zeit möglich gewesen, mit einem Ticket auf dem Stehplatzbereich von Block M bis zu Block O bis zu Block K zu laufen. Das war früher immer möglich. Und diesen Vibe will man behalten. Der Stadionname soll verkauft werden. Da gibt es gerade noch ein bisschen Diskussionen. Es gab einen Aufruf von der Fanszene. Das kann ich verstehen, aber abwarten. Das ist gerade hochgebrannt.
Und wie läuft es mit der Finanzierung? Preußen Münster wird keine großen Reserven haben. Nämlich an, ist das in Zusammenarbeit mit der Stadt oder dem Land?
Die Stadt zahlt 88 Millionen.
Okay. Und dann?
Der Verein wird dann Miete zahlen. So ist das, glaube ich, so veranschlagt. Okay. Es waren vorher 50 bis 60 Millionen und durch die ganzen geschiegenen baukosten wurde es nochmal aufgestockt. Davor hatte ja der Verein selber gesucht im Umland, also ich sage mal so im Umland 20 Kilometer Umkreis. Und das war erstmal mit Zustimmung und dann gab es aber da im Umland ziemlich viel Teno dagegen. Dann wurde es angestampft und dann hat die Stadt selbst entschieden, okay, jetzt machen wir das hier. Wir sind aber auf maximal 20.000 gedeckelt. Also mehr geht an dem Standort nicht.
Gut, das ist dann die mittel- bis langfristige zukunft. Du hast jetzt kurzfristig nur auf die Saison geguckt, Sven. Was muss passieren, dass du am Ende der Saison, selbst wenn da ein Abstieg stehen sollte, wer weiß. Aber wann würdest du diese Saison als eine schöne, gute, erfolgreiche bezeichnen? Wann tritt da so eine innere Zufriedenheit vielleicht ein?
Also ich bin jetzt 42 und ich habe 1988 in der Jugend von Preußen Münster angefangen. Ich habe 1989 das 2 zu 1 von Preußen Münster gegen Schalke 04, die Leistungsteilung, erlebt auf der Aschebahn. Ich habe einige schöne Erfolge erlebt und ich habe genau dann den Abgang erlebt, von der 2. Liga in die 3., dann in die 4.. Ganz ehrlich, für jeden Preußen-Fan, wenn ich jetzt Hamburg nehme, mit 8.000 Preußen-Fans auswärts mal in einem Stall hinzustehen, die Chance hatten wir nicht. Natürlich sind jetzt viele neue Fans dabei, aber die werden vielleicht auch von Eventi-Fans zu regulären Fans. Aber das war schon so ein Meilenstein, wo ich sagen würde, okay, cool. Dadurch, dass wir ohne infrastruktur, wir haben ja noch niemanden ein richtiges Nachwuchs- Leistungszentrum, was wir ja bieten müssten. Unser Stadion, unsere ganze infrastruktur passt ja auch noch nicht. Das, was wir jetzt mit dem Aufstieg in die 3. Liga geschafft hatten, wo wir schon sehr zufrieden waren, und das, was wir in der 3. Liga dann erleben konnten, mit dem Last-Minute-Aufstieg in die 2. Liga, das kann uns keiner nehmen. Ja, was erwarten wir für die 2. Liga? Ich glaube, da fehlt so ein bisschen Geld für große Transfers, weil du im Grunde genommen von der ganzen infrastruktur, die du ja für die 2. Liga aufbereiten musst, das ist ja Kameratechnik, Torlinientechnik und so weiter, da redest du von 1,4 Millionen. Ja, die werden hier von den TV-Geldern schon wieder abgezogen. Ja, dann ist ja nicht mehr viel, ne? Also von daher ist jeder Punkt ist Kampf, jeder Punkt ist geil und jedes Erlebnis im Stadion, also Nürnberg war es auch geil. Ich freue mich auf Hannover, ich freue mich auch auf Braunschweig nächste Woche, Elvesberg vielleicht nicht, aber Hamburg, Hamburg, Wahnsinn. Also von daher, jeder Preußenfan nimmt das mit. Es wird momentan, es kippt ein bisschen an der Stimmung, das merkt man schon, weil Elvesberg richtig scheiße war, aber davor war es okay und man weiß gar nicht so, wo ist man mit dem Kader, wo kann man dahin kommen, weil immer das System verändert worden ist, die Aufstellung wurde verändert. Schwierig, ist schwierig. Wenn ich einen Badmatt sette, einen Morfzer mit der Erfahrung, mit dem ich schieße einfach an Tore, spielt sie wahrscheinlich anders als eben genau, dass sie jetzt gucken muss, wie Ausfälle zu kompensieren. Es ist schwierig.
Dann kommen wir auf ein konjunktiv zu feststehenden Ding und feststeht ist, dass diese Sendung nun vorbei ist, ein Ende hat. Ich danke euch beiden sehr für die Zeit, Thomas Haufe vom Nuhr, FCM-Podcast und Sven Scholz von 06.de. Vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr mir und den HörerInnen, die eure Vereine näher gebracht habt.
Sehr gerne.
Sehr gerne. Vielen Dank. Schönen Abend.
Und dann sprechen wir vielleicht in ein paar Monaten nochmal, wenn der FCM plötzlich wirklich furios an den Aufstieg mitspielt und Preußen Münster es doch gepackt hat, sich aus den 3., Rängen oder so rauszulassen. Aber das werden wir alles weiter beobachten, da es noch viel Zeit vergehen muss. Aber bis dahin, liebe Grüße an alle, die die Folge gehört haben.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.